in 2017 NASA's Cassini probe sent us our
closest view of Saturn as it douve into
the planet's stormy atmosphere and the
results were stunning but what would it
be like if humans made the journey in
person at its closest Saturn is 1.2
billion kilometres away from Earth so
with today's spacecraft technology
you'll need about eight years to make
the trip finally you arrive and get your
first glimpse of Saturn with your own
eyes
it's an enormous planet the second
largest in the solar system
in fact over 760 earths can fit inside
but hold up we can't visit Saturn and
skip over the best part its iconic rings
Saturn's rings are almost as wide as the
distance between the Earth and the moon
so at first glance they seem like an
easy place to land and explore on foot
except there's one problem
while they look like giant discs they're
not a solid track at all instead they're
made of millions of chunks of ice some
as Tiny as dust particles others as
large as buses but if you were able to
hike on one of Saturn's outermost rings
you'll walk about twelve million
kilometres to make it around the longest
one that's about 15 round trips from the
earth to the moon along the way you'll
come across tiny moons and spokes of
dust levitating above the surface now
you might notice that streams of tiny
ice particles are also flying off the
Rings heading towards Saturn that's ring
rain it turns out Saturn's magnetic
fields are slowly but surely draining
away the Rings so we're lucky to visit
the Rings now because every 30 minutes
they lose enough water to fill an
olympic-sized swimming pool and if we
arrived 300 million years in the future
we miss them
entirely now let's climb back aboard and
visit the planet itself 282 thousand
kilometers away as we reach the North
Pole will notice a slight problem with
our plan to land on the surface below
there is no surface below
Saturn's made almost entirely of
hydrogen and helium gas which is why
it's called a gas giant four thousand
kilometres above the surface we hit
Saturn's upper atmosphere as we plummet
through the North Pole
we'll be treated to the site of a
magnificent Aurora like the ones we see
in Alaska it turns out Saturn's magnetic
field generates huge electrical currents
which heat up the atmosphere at the
poles
unfortunately the electrical activity
within this Aurora can disrupt our ships
electronics and navigation system so
best marvel at a distance next we'll hit
the troposphere the part of the
atmosphere where weather happens so
watch out powerful winds may slam into
us at nearly 400 meters per second
that's over three times faster than the
strongest hurricanes on earth all around
us thick yellow clouds give the planet
its color these are filled with ammonia
crystals if you take a sniff you might
be able to smell that distinctive scent
but you should probably keep the window
closed ammonia is very irritating and
could wreak havoc on your respiratory
system plus it's freezing out here
reaching as low as minus 250 degrees
Celsius much colder than the East
Antarctic Plateau the coldest place on
earth so let's head down where it's a
bit warmer down here at a depth of three
hundred kilometres we reach a layer of
water which is a balmy zero degrees
Celsius
now the deeper we plunge the higher the
pressure is around us
and in this next layer the pressure is
so high it forces those liquid water
molecules together creating solid ice
that ice mixes in with surrounding gases
so get ready to fight through a flurry
of hail hopefully the ice won't shred
our ship to pieces but if we make it
through get ready to go for a swim
because 1,000 kilometers into the
interior the pressure is so high it
forces hydrogen molecules together into
a liquid which doesn't bode well for us
since even the sturdiest submarine would
be crushed in these conditions and if we
somehow survive to reach the next layer
we'll hit yet another obstacle a layer
of liquid metallic hydrogen the problem
here is that this metal can conduct
electricity so even if our navigation
equipment and electronics escape the
Aurora upstairs it's probably down for
the count now but if we could survive
here our final stop might uncover a
mystery in the deepest depths of Saturn
you see
scientists suspect Saturn has a core
made of iron and nickel but they're not
sure if it's liquid like the previous
layer or solid like Earth's core so
maybe we'll be the lucky ones to find
out once and for all
though it's over 83,000 degrees Celsius
in here hotter than the surface of the
Sun and hot enough to dissolve our
spacecraft with us inside hmm maybe we
should leave the Saturn exploration to
unmanned probes after all
you